[Music]
[Music]
over a century ago a German doctor
called Alice Alzheimer spotted anomalies
in brain sections from a patient with
dementia ever since people have been
studying the strange plaques and tangles
that he saw in the hope that we could
one day understand and cure what is now
known as Alzheimer's disease
[Music]
plaques are insoluble deposits of a
peptide called amyloid beta or a beta
they're formed when a protein called
amyloid precursor protein is
sequentially cleaved by two enzymes beta
and gamma secretase other molecules are
generated by this cleavage and may play
a role in the disease but a beta is the
main culprit a beta tends to miss fold
and become sticky eventually clumping
together to form soluble oligomers some
of these aggregate into large in the
soluble fibrillar the deposit in the
brain as plaques the oligomers come in
several forms or species we don't know
exactly which species are toxic but
research shows that they linked in
communication and plasticity at sign
APS's this could be what stops the brain
and forming or retrieving memories
neurons aren't the only cells affected
in Alzheimer's disease astrocytes are
microglia also play a role microglia our
immune cells that clear out waste and
prune synapse is during development
microglia take up a beta but they also
get activated by it triggering the
release of inflammatory cytokines that
can damage neurons the microglia also
start to remove sign APS's by
phagocytosis
as sign apses start to malfunction and
neurons die abnormal patterns of
activity emerge and eventually the brain
can't process and store information
properly another key feature of
Alzheimer's disease is neuro
degeneration neuronal death and damage
is triggered by a beta but some of ABT's
effects seem to be mediated by another
protein seen in the brains of patients
tau a component of tangles in a healthy
neuron molecules are carried along the
axon on a series of tracks made of
microtubules and stabilized by town but
in Alzheimer's disease tau is modified
causing it to dissociate from the
microtubules adopt an abnormal shape and
move from the apps onto the cell body
like a beta tau comes in a variety of
forms and we don't know which ones
contribute to the disease and like a
beta these forms either remain soluble
or stick together and deposit as the
tangles that dr. Alzheimer saw
eventually these processes kill the
neuron another problem seen in animal
models is that Mis folded tau proteins
can spread across synapses into healthy
neurons there they makes healthy tau
proteins start to miss faults as well
spreading pathology across the brain
the pattern of spreading through the
different brain regions matches the
changing symptoms from early to late
stages of Alzheimer's disease this
pattern also reflects how certain
neurons are more vulnerable than others
to dying
despite these advances in our
understanding of Alzheimer's disease no
cure exists while drugs are being
developed to target amyloid beta or tau
it's unclear whether they will
eventually be successful in treating the
disease there's only one certainty
continued support for basic and clinical
research will enable us one day to
diagnose and treat this devastating
condition
you